turn my turn my turn them into viewers
viewers viewers wait this is really
close how about this how about I make a
viewer tournament and we'll compromise
let's make a viewer tournaments I
haven't done one of these in a long long
time how do I even make a tournament
tournament create new tournaments
we'll make it like five plus zero I
guess it's like quick enough but not
absurdly like long and we can get out
get in enough games so initial thought
time five minutes duration I'll make it
an hour two minutes to join I think this
is good enough I'll share the link in
the chat to make things easier for
people Oh toilet leg in said three Oh
too late
can i play stockfish 10 I could but not
now its bits from coward calling
thanks for the bits have I tried the
other strategy games like Japanese chess
or shogi or wait is that just one game
Japanese chess show you is that separate
or the same thing I tried learning shogi
once I was I was with a friend a
grandmaster Yuri Shulman who went
through like a shogi phase and he was
trying to teach me but I didn't get very
far because I couldn't distinguish the
pieces because all the pieces are just
like Japanese characters and they're
just like all these squiggly lines and I
was just too difficult to keep track of
everything but it seemed like an
interesting concept like seems very
comparable to like crazy house you like
take a piece and you put it back on the
board
other games that I'm into are Scrabble
and boggle I like word games and more
recently this game Settlers of Catan
which I was playing with other chess
players and there's an app for it but
nothing has really stuck to much
I have considered streaming Scrabble
though because there are like some
internet Scrabble club sites oh this
training starts very soon I share the
link I figured if I shared the link I'll
share it one more time how many players
are there who's 37 players already okay
looks like I'm gonna play a Palo six
first round what's berserk no mercy this
time I'll be aggressive because it's
blitz see what he wants to do ok playing
the stafford gambits this is like by far
oh and my favorite blitz openings cuz
there's so many traps and bitter b2 is
probably the best move I have to
remember what to do I think we need you
6
so far he's playing pretty much
correctly like ensuring that I can't
play my g4 but we'll see if he can keep
it up ah maybe I should have played
Queen d4 I forgot to play Queen d4 ooh I
can still play Queen d4 because earlier
at fish of e3 I could take on b2 but
here it's almost just as good yes to
make some concession there's only one
move for light the problem is I don't
really have that much I'm low on time
because I desert wow so we have a
hundred eighty-one subs which is far
more than just an hour ago I played
Bishop b6 Queen D it's kind of
depressing do I have to do that probably
I played there should be six so d4
doesn't attack my bishop that way if he
plays d4 I just win the plum so he's up
upon but still a little bit
underdeveloped and he can't castle so
arguably there's still some compensation
there's a really cool move I want to
play here which I think I'll play it
violates some principles mainly leaving
and I can attacked by a pond but we'll
see if he sees a threat I want to play
ninety three and fork
let's do it I was also threatening Queen
h4 with force mates so Knight f3 defend
against sad at least but now I have a
bishop in his territory which is
actually kind of hard to remove this
Bishop has no legal moves and my bishop
prevents stuff will probably prevent
black or from prevent light from
castling later let's put the Queen here
or d6 maybe d6 I'll just keep making
threats and hope he misses amor just
gets tired from defending them I think
there's only one move here for White's
you wonder that I see because this is a
monster threat
maybe there's a few moves
yeah that was the one who that I saw I'm
gonna put the coin in each six now I'm
threatening just to win the pawn back
these pawns look strong but I think
they're a little bit overextended I also
have the idea of playing queen up for
just trying to find my way to f2
concrete chess is that when the chess
pieces are made out of concrete as
opposed to wood chess so you depends
upon so I'm just gonna keep making
threats this is what we call initiative
where every move you just make a threat
and you keep the opponent on the defense
if you somehow defends g3 and then I'll
probably play c5 keeping the initiative
I also couldn't maybe just take the
knight and win the pond
I'm also threatening g2 so he plays
Bishop f3 but that allows Queen g3
Keeney two's force and I can take this
and now the scheme can not get off the
e-file they can move back but doesn't
really help I'm threatening a large
number of discovery checks oh there is a
move here for a white bishop me for
that's the best move now my bishop is
undefended I could just take the knight
yeah and I'll do it and now somehow I'm
up a pawn
with a decent position I can still
castle either side and b-2s attached so
I'm keeping initiative even more Queen
b3 could move Castle kingside
I think I'll castle or I'll play Bishop
g7 first I'm trying to bait him into
taking the pawn if he takes a pawn I'll
be happy because the open file is more
valuable than the pawn so Queen takes b7
I just Castle kingside
and if not I probably Castle queenside
so I'm finally up on time I counselled
queenside because I want Brooke here in
here as quickly as possible you might
have some attack though to be a little
bit careful
Brooke before I probably have to play b6
if he attacks a pawn I might have to
play a 5:14 b7 it should be safe though
and I have enough time perpetual check
me already has four points and I have
yet to score any tournament points wait
is my mic bad
hopefully it's not too bad apologies if
it was too bad I'm gonna attack the rook
I'm not threatening to take the rook all
right am i I am The Queen okay he's
gonna flag hopefully I'll trade Queens
and now I have a pawn diamonds I was
nice I like this formation
okay back to tournaments those
interesting kind of hard-fought game
Stafford yam it's all about initiative
yeah all you issues persist let me know
I'm next to an airports so I feel like
there could be like frequencies in the
air or something we have a scandi let's
play before I didn't say this beforehand
but I might try and play gambits every
every game in this trenchant but he
declines again it's but gives me some
leading developments b5 is gonna come
again I think it's all about initiative
like my next several moves should be
attacking black slowing down development
while improving position like 94
probably coming next for those of you
who just joined if you want to play in
this tournament I'm doing kind of a
surprise viewer tournament I'm leaving a
link in the chat you'll have a chance to
play me I don't know how many players
there are when it started there were 37
ok so the Queen's attacked now he's
attacking my rook let's defend and he's
attacking the pawn too so let's play
this may be preparing this f5 would be
interesting I fight probably d4 so
attacking the Queen
and developing if he takes on v5 I take
on a six of nine bishop
yeah there's a airplane coming overhead
I'm very curious if people can hear it I
feel like the mic should do a good
enough job not allowing background noise
to come through Oh 73 players playing
now nice my bishops are immaculate he's
these are like the Danish gambit bishops
but I'm not downing material I'm ready
to castle life is so good and he's not
developed but he's about to be developed
so how do i punish him maybe f4 f5 I
just keep attacking the Queen if Queen
here then d4 and I want to open up the
center files before he can castle so at
some point I'll play one of these pawn
Drake's
I think f5 makes the most sense I want
to open up the files were my major
pieces sits like it's moved 17 and still
black only has the Queen developed it's
like nothing has changed since move to
okay Bishop d6 oh he wants to castle but
let's take the pawn if Bishop takes I
play d5 oh I can't play d5 because it's
pinned oops let's play c4 threatening
this
more bits from sarony Leo thanks for the
bits every time I stream it seems like
serenella was cheering 500 bits I was
watching one of my like old YouTube like
archived streams other day and I think
it was a video like the very first time
Sarah nelio cheered because I was trying
to pronounce his name
but now it's just second nature let's
play this like the queen is almost
trapped the Queen has to move here and
then at the very least I can win the
pawn at the very most I'm winning
everything bishop c6 check and then d5
probably whoa he's sacking let's mmm do
I want to take life choices
let's take because it's material I'll
play King h1 I want to play d5 but I
didn't want to allow Bishop takes e5
with check now d5 he just takes it but
then Queen e5 so tactics
I think it works if he doesn't take it
then d6 might come
Kiyomi wants to join the tournament but
your food won't burn are you torturing
your food you could join the tournament
and like hire a butler maybe ooh mate it
was easier to see the bishop attacked
than the battery long distance okay back
to tournaments hey I'm in lead first
place out of 87 players are we gonna hit
100 players for this tournament for
those watching you can join by clicking
the link in the chat but people are
close behind Daniel Moreno Dan omarina
was like maybe one of the first-ever
viewers to my stream definitely within
the first like fifty maybe first twenty
okay so waiting for a game
only 14 minutes in lot more chests to be
played playing chess 11 good luck I'm
gonna play the same opening I played the
first game or the yeah the first game if
he takes I play 96 usually good sign
when white starts thinking here I have
to assume that everyone playing me is
also watching the stream so this time he
doesn't take the Knights which allows me
to win back the pawn and now I have
Knights in the center I've had games
recently where players play Queen e2 or
then I would have to play Queen e7 and
break the pin and it leads to maybe some
slightly better position for black
because black has already had like
slightly ahead in development
mmm I'm tempted to take on f2 just going
completely insane
but let's not there's an opening called
the costume gambit where a white sacks a
piece like this against the petrov but
in the costume gambit white has two
Center pawns
speaking of center funds if you plays d4
it's complete completely symmetrical but
he doesn't okay that's good
now I'm threatening pawn d4
and again I want a castle and / maybe
try and prevent light from castling if I
got a rook to eat what is fork Knights
you tell me is it for tonight if the
knight is doing the forking or if the
night is getting forts not entirely sure
okay now Rick Ian is actually a move but
he takes some precautions I think I'll
play Queen d6 this is a multi-purpose
move first of all I get out of the pen
secondly I want to play Knight me for at
some point and leave the bishop awkward
because I'm also preventing Bishop f4
now the question is do I play 94
immediately or do I take first let's
take first conceding the bishop pair
that this Knight is now very powerful
and it's kind of working stuff oh I
forgot to Mazurek this game so I have
time that's nice
I'm pretty sure my stream like category
is still playing chess and not playing
fortnight
I wonder if ice if I switched it to
fortnight's but was still playing chess
if I would get more viewers that way
probably not so I mean the bishop could
move back to d2 but that looks very very
passive between d3 Bishop f5 is the
first move that comes to mind no need to
calculate just align the bishop with the
Queen if the Queen moves to e3 I line
align my rook with the Queen it's always
a good thing at least like middle game
strategy wise to align your lesser
valuable pieces with your opponent's
more valuable pieces
it's like bishops and rooks aligned with
your pawns kings and queens can lead to
tactics in this case I'm threatening
some Knight g3 move with a fork Knights
prefer regular openings maybe next game
I'll play a regular opening what opening
do you prefer maybe I'll take some
recommendations night g3 wouldn't run
into Queen Dix g3 so let's just win upon
bishops also not defended them I know my
bishop is also not defended so I win the
pawn first and now I'm defending my
bishop I was writing to win White's
bishop I'm also threatening moves like
Knight takes f2 with discovery this
looks nice he 45 well that was this game
me 45 I play the kind of obscure opening
emerging from a 45 London is - Queens
gambit but what does a fettuccini
this is a free Bishop and I keep
initiative and the Queen is tied down to
defending this Bishop if Queen e3 I
probably just trade Queens can you play
the URIs off gambit I actually don't
know too much about the URIs off gambits
it's one of these open things I should
like take some take like a day to study
but yeah I only know like the first few
moves but I haven't dug too deeply into
the the variations yet England gambits I
guess it depends what my opponent plays
or who I play and then okay what we're a
SPOC just asking caro-kann French is
that c6 combined with e6
let's just play French
French is fun sometimes when you win and
French is an opening that I've actually
played a couple times in tournament play
as a surprise weapon and actually both
turned in games I had went into this
line like this 92 line so this is still
preparation and I know a little bit
about this variation I like to play a
side line here involving B 6 and then
our C 5 and then B six simple positional
idea of trading off my worst piece for
whites best piece so that's what I would
do there's a lot of these types of lines
in the French you can play bit more off
beats like off main line it's preserving
the bishop just interesting but now my
bishop is just so happy along this
diagonal if Queen a4 forking I probably
play Queen C eights defending and
there's some annoying pressure on upon
which she takes care of I don't think I
want to castle though castling would be
risky
so what did you
like b5 actually was teaching the other
day and I was showing a student very
similar position I was telling them the
plan with b5 so I guess I'll go for this
like b5 before trying to undermine
White's pawn chain uh Eddie 1 139 I know
exactly what you're talking about with
the fettuccine like Alejandra Ramirez
teaching little kids openings and one of
the kids said fettuccine when they meant
to say fianchetto and then Alejandro
couldn't stop laughing that was an old
video - okay before let's do it my
bishop is happy again and wants to play
Knight h5 and induce some weaknesses so
now I think I'll play g6 it's very
common for black to leave the King in
the center in these types of structures
because the center is closed and usually
white tries to attack on the Kings side
meanwhile black wants to attack on the
Queen side or at least play positionally
sometimes h5 is included too to
discourage g4 but h5 might invite like
some sacrifice on g6 I think for now I
can just wow 92 didn't he just plain I
left four so he's just losing time like
I just got a bunch of Freeman's I got
this and this and this and he just did
this and ice that's hard true for white
to actually figure out what to do here
because it's not easy to develop the
Queen side if he moves a bishop it might
have invited like the Queen coming to be
- it's another reason why I like this
line because if I don't Castle kingside
then white doesn't have it clear like
attacking plan maybe I'll play Bishop h6
but we'll see Bishop e3 okay
so takes takes and Queen B - you
probably moves the bishop - C - I'm just
going to leave all the tension plateless
like when in doubt when pawns are
attacking each other
it's not a bad idea to just leave them
be if he ever takes it probably benefits
me somehow he takes this way there's
less defense here h4 so you wants to
play h5 thinking about this maneuver get
the Knight to c4 but do I play h5 first
probably not he's h5 I mean what's the
threat if he takes I take back I feel
like is Knight should've stay on f4
what do i play against Knight c3 when I
play the French it's an interesting
question because usually when I if I
play the French and the tournaments I'll
only play French against players who
play Knight d2 because I don't want to
mess with the 93 lines if I had to
prepare something I'd probably prepare
either Fort Knox
it was just solid if you know what
you're doing which is essentially
Rubinstein French with Bishop d7 Bishop
c6 or I would prepare some of like one
of these weird and win over sidelines
like where you play what is it Bishop b4
against Knight c3 and then when they
play e5 play and move like Queen d7 some
deeper positional ideas want to take but
I also want to play Knight c4 let's play
Knight c4 first
if h5i might consider a g5 and then if
not three I would have a fork Knights
Queen c2 really applying pressure to g6
but g6 is still pretty solid I'm now
gonna take because if we trade Queens I
feel like more of the focus will be on
the Queen side and maybe I can make
further progress there's also some idea
Bishop takes h4 and Knight takes h4 and
g5 again without fork Knights there how
many times I can say fork knight in this
stream well he's about to lose on time
so that's also nice congratulations
pearline for winning a game den c-121 is
a new chess player let me focus for a
moment attacking this any sevens
undefended
but his rook is hanging so probably
Bishop b5 there should be five Queens XA
seven Queen takes a one might have my
rook
whose Bishop takes g6 with discovery
then I probably take the rook and then
take this bishop so I lost a queen but I
got a rook another rook and the bishop
for it
he got Queen and pawn so technically won
some material let's retreat the bishop
hey bro tech hosting with six viewers is
out of the chest stream it doesn't
something familiar
thanks for tuck or is it per talk okay
let's plug this guy Bishop e7 and
bishops e8
is that trapping the Queen where does
the Queen move free Queen you get to
move to c6 I think this is almost a
queen trap Queen c6 Knight a5 Queen c7
Bishop here wait I think this is
actually trapping the Queen and it's
it's funny because a lot of these moves
are retreating looks like starting with
Bishop d7 the only safe Queen move is
Queen c6 when I play Knight a5 for
treating the only safe Queen move here
is Queen c7 then I retreat again
Bishop's d8 the only safe Queen move is
Queen d6 and then rip b6 chops of Queen
that would have been nice but okay it's
good enough back to tournaments oh I was
passed by maybe Scott G okay it's
getting competitive and Daniel Moreno
tied for first also doing some biz
irking
all right there is a question from den
see I'm a very neutral and I play e45 as
white and black I respond to d4 with the
Kings Indian okay I like positions where
I get black as Kings India and are there
openings I can play I mean you could
play the Kings Indian attack you're
asking if there's openings you can play
to get a similar structure as whites
just look up Kings Indian attack type
into Google Kings Indian attack chess
games and you should get a list of games
from a website chess games calm and
you'll see how White's attacks with the
Kings Indian attack it's a nice opening
if you like that structure so there's a
hundred twenty four people playing this
tournament maybe you should do more
tournaments like this speaking ok let's
play the Kings Indian attack if I'm
talking about that opening also thanks
for the bits heart lies in riddle all
he's showing up oh I forgot to busy so
essentially this is over wrist Kings
Indian but the plans usually stay the
same with eventually playing E for
provoking d4 and then going for eventual
f4 f5 so I play 91 to prepare this and
he's not castling which may be not a bad
strategy if he castles King side them
and I just attack on the Kings side
castling queenside makes things
interesting because I'm in shape to
attack on the Kings side but now he's
trying to attack on the Kings side
what's going on I think I can take this
and have a fork
it's a little bit complicated though yes
up from and a tenuous life
thanks for the sub okay he's thinking
he's realizing the danger probably
I know what I would do here if I were
black but I'm not gonna say it because I
don't want to give him any clues what do
I think about the woodpecker method I
actually don't know what that is
I've heard it mentioned Knight takes d4
is the best move unfortunately for me
yeah maybe I'm not winning material
sadly that's a good move
takes try and just keep initiative
though oh he could take the Queen you
could also just like leave my knight
pinned
so no maybe you forgot five or Queenie -
yeah the position isn't actually that's
like attractive for lights you can also
take and play King each one which
doesn't look attractive you'll play
Queenie - getting my queen off the file
is empty for maybe rook c1 OC sevens of
targets he's playing very very fast
Knight g4 maybe work out fine
we've got five takes thinking I could
take with Queen and he know that he can
take this is scary
if I take
my king doesn't want to be on g1
okay try and play it as safe as I can
now I'm feeling a little bit more
comfortable as if h4g for as long as the
H file doesn't open should be okay he
might win a pawn and b2 but oops I just
turned off the lights Queen f7 singing
that's an unexpected gift now see you
sevens attacks Wow things are gonna get
complex I think I'm gonna take here I
don't think taking works if he takes end
it'll be two rooks for Queen and some
pawns you know take on each for first
how many pawns do I have I have three
pawns and a queen for the two rooks so
it should be better as long as the rooks
can't coordinate - well there's some
tactic like if takes h4 f Queen g3 with
a fork rook therefore Queen Queen Fork
what tournament is this this is a the I
am Eric Rosen Arena you can join if you
want just click the link in the chat I
can take on a seven maybe let's take a
seven another free pawn if he takes on
d3 I fork again so the great thing about
a queen in an open position there's so
many potential Forks if pieces are left
undefended
time situation not too bad taking me 5
min Roxy six it's two let's do this
first
mmm maybe this and that'll be five next
and he can't actually save both rooks
cuz it's a skewer like normally the
rooks could defend each other somehow
but e5 also covers f6 and he
counter-attacks anyway
like rook f1 just King G - okay that was
nice
maybe not the best demonstration of the
Kings Indian attack but at least I got
to show like the Mesa opening setup at
some point my position was not so
preferable but somehow it worked out so
Daniel Moreno meeting the tournament
buzzer King more than die more than me
well I get to play him he's playing
right now would actually prefer black in
that position I'll see what happens
let's beserk I'll play aggressively well
we have a Budapest please play c4 yeah
that's a problem with the pests can't
play anything it's 9 f3 so I'll play a q
GD III let's play a semi Slav c5 c5 is
usually a positional mistake because of
a 5 I learned this idea back when I was
like 7 or 800 rated in fact when I was I
think 8 years old my first chess coach
taught me this and I was so happy to
like learn it as it shows the beauty of
like pawn structure II being destroyed
in this pot I don't think can be
defended
how about grubs I don't play the grub
most of the time okay let's take
I feel like there's a decent chance he's
gonna run into some like queen a5 tactic
like if Queen b3 I take and play maybe I
can't do it here maybe I can play 94
first if he takes on g7 I don't know
what's going on
we need four maybe I shouldn't allow
that
that's okay I still have initiative I'm
threatening to take here I've threats of
25 material is equal my Center's decent
more bits from the Damian
thanks for the bits so Queen a5 still an
idea that and the goal is just to
prevent light from castling if 92 I take
and play 94 again
some night spins I don't have too much
time to think takes takes I won't play
rook b8 but I don't think that bricks
car alarms going off
I don't know I'm gonna play f5 idea of
some real ifs maybe not the best move
trying to do something move three nights
rook t1 would have been probably best
for whites like over defending and then
preparing to castle expecting ooh I was
not expecting that forgot about that
move I think I'm okay
like there's no checks to the king if
you talk to c6 I have liked this move oh
there's that check oh my gosh I might be
losing this way I can't that's not even
legal I have to run
oh this is very unpleasant completely
forgot about Queen g7
at least I'm not like completely dead
yet I think Bishop d7 keeps me alive
whether it's the pollen count pawn count
is equal so I'm just down the exchange a
knight is centralized could be much
worse could be better - like given the
opening bits from the damien don't
distract me this is a pressure situation
he's attacking this what do I even do
how do I defend night this is so
unpleasant I don't see how to defend any
queens three and then Rock d8 of 19
seconds left and this is rated - no oh
maybe I play I'm gonna play Knight c5
at least I have a night's nights are
tricky
so down upon down to pons and the
exchange and I'm losing h7 please take
it
Queen trade
well I have two connected passers like
despite being down to pawns I have
passed pawns maybe makes life better
oh I'm only down one pawn because I
can't count good pre move this but I
only have 15 seconds that's the worst
part nice it's not too difficult to push
pawns quickly
are we gonna see another Fork night it's
possible I want to put the knight in d3
bring the king in I don't know allow him
to sack though
so my knight is actually as powerful as
a rook in this type of position maybe
I'll put the knot on b3 put the King on
c5 and play d4
he's getting lower in time which I like
to see 13 seconds it's not much but
should be enough
pre-move d4 maybe I shouldn't have cream
of d4 block is triple pawns
mmm those Kings gonna help out but my
pawns are still trolling well let's take
but they work on a seven nine seconds
left he's running low too
yeah I think I'm gonna flag him but he
played well I might be winning on the
board too but I don't know it's so
complex
I was probably losing in the final
position good game though a nil Chon Duk
like the opening was great for me and
then I I lost you seven which is
unnecessary and 94 was a little bit
careless all right back to tournaments I
know I'm chasing two people maybe scotch
gee there's not much time to catch up
there's only 13 minutes left 14 minutes
left
that's like maybe two more games so I
pretty much have to dessert I'm probably
gonna play Daniel Moreno yeah by bezerk
I probably berserk if I want to win the
tournament I'll play at London my score
against him is good I've only lost one
game I was the first game we've ever
played look at that very first game we
played that may have been in a Simon oh
this wasn't a Syme Alya this game - oh
you played well so I'm working against
the number one ranked player
I have to play fast I want to play one
more game after this to queen bee 693 is
usually the best way to me queen bee 694
defend our attacking and defending
so we're gonna have some Kings Indian
set up yeah be five double-edged move a
four might come trying to undermine the
structure let's play Queen c2 preparing
me for also may be preparing b3 the
bishop here
you know probably b3 will come like
similar type of ideas last game
Bishop d5 probably queen bee too
meanwhile I want to play rook up C 1 and
C 4
if he takes on a four I play c4
immediately also attacking the pawn
three times so let's take and when upon
maybe he takes one C 3 we tray that 186
otherwise I'm winning b5
I'll take with the Queen Queen should
not get chopped I was FD three or back
to be one so I'm up upon c4 should still
come and maybe even c5 because my bishop
his effective time is almost equal OC 3
hyung forget about c3 yeah it's gonna be
equal no advantage for white completely
forgot the pawn was hanging maybe I
should have played rook c1 first
so we both have one pawn island but
there is room to play for something
we'll trade off
take the bishop away maybe play Bishop
f3 or Bishop g4 soon
efore doesn't quite work let's play rook
Oh No let's play G we're on f3 bishop f2
in g4 maybe even Bishop me one put the
King on f2 looks weird but should be
solid he wants a trade
ok fine with trading my bishop will
enter e6 maybe d5 at some points
clicking back on e2
and I want to trade too much
creating a lot of tension though Wow
it's take and attack this jaw if you
place King off six side this doesn't
work let's take and maybe night see five
active night's king f6f four or even
ninety seven its playoff for first I
think I'm winning upon threatening to
fork the king and night fork nights I
could fork Bishop well I could just fork
and win the bishop and then win the
pawns
maybe I'm winning both bonds
mmm this night stuck too let's go
activate the King and win the bishop
okay somehow it worked out I think he
was the bishop on a just got way too
passive wasn't useful Oh so this guy's
leading he's unna youichi ha buzzer King
and winning every game strong player 147
players in the tournament I don't think
I'll get a chance to play him he's about
to win another game or is he no he's not
gonna win that and he's down upon I
don't know what the time situation is
oh he's buzzer key I'm buzzer 'king
everyone's buzzer King oh yeah he's not
gonna win that okay so I basically just
need to win this game and then maybe
I'll even have time for one more for
both buzzer King and playing
aggressively IG for so many people play
this like d3 Knight c3 walk into Knight
g4 Queen e2 allowing some Massacre this
looks very nice when I tour g3 takes 42
not seeing the win but
I could just take on me for you know
just castle and maybe go for f5 you then
this is just so nice you know I I can
always consider winning the rook
I just want to leave my knight here that
slows down any development make this
Queen box of Bishop blocks or if King
has blocked let's play f5 just increased
pressure maybe you get the rook into the
game
take and attack the queen
Queens III probably be 56
talking upon also maybe see five ideas
in 96 so he was going for the fork so
I'm aligning my queen with his king also
allowing my last piece to come into the
game so now it's just a matter of
winning quickly let's do this almost
winning the Queen but not quite it's
Queen III
first I thought he'd disconnected
so the Queen's are getting traded but
the attack against the King will
continue and whites gonna flag and he
disconnected I'm not the best connection
okay back to tournaments I'm in the lead
and the guy behind me lost a game so bow
but he's about to win this one so he'll
get three points for winning right then
I need to win one more game but there's
only three minutes left in the
tournament better start soon giant mouse
no I'm gonna play him too I don't want
to play him he just passed me well this
will be difficult was irking okay
through the past
hey he's playing the Carlson variation
not realizing that I played the Budapest
put the knight year allowing Queen f6
whoa he's just blundering okay I thought
this was gonna be a bit more difficult
please just for Zion let's take the rook
and do this
maybe d4 coming
given d3
I'll put my ruck under it
this is still gonna be difficult to win
moving the night if he takes one be
seven maybe c6 Bishop is almost trapped
well 95 and my queen is almost trapped I
have to play Queenie aids in weird
position the scheme is not going to
finish before the tournament ends
unfortunately but I'll at least try and
win it just to get some cried
let's play this try and trap the bishop
attack the pawn may be preparing Queen
a3
Bishop b4 doesn't look right let's just
do this if Queen digs d3 I have c5 okay
that does uh plunder upon hmm let's just
be safe
defending c6 as well now c5 and now the
H punch and hang the tournment is ending
no so yeah he officially won the
tournament but I am hopefully going to
officially win this game I play like
Bishop h3 it's a cool move maybe not the
most necessary move but it looks cool
attacking and if this line and then if
he takes a bishop I have some fun move
back attacking the pawn
but they work here
I still want to take the pawn he takes
my pond let's attack the bishop
keep attacking
after workout three rook c1
okay so I went undefeated someone trying
to cheer like over a billion bits it
doesn't quite work like that Eric
probably needs to do a video about how
to play the Budapest for black do you
subscribe to me on youtube because I've
done three videos this month actually at
the being the beginning of the month
like January 1st through the 3rd and
they're all labeled like Budapest like
cool tricks and traps and stuff so
anyway 2nd place congratulations to my
opponents as you know youichi ha no idea
if i pronounced that correctly well that
was fun
hope you guys enjoyed that we had almost
150 players 149 so i'll probably do more
of tournaments of so many people play